voici maintenant la vérité mais cinq
dernières minutes
te
ben laden dès les premières minutes et
michel piccoli bonjour
on est vraiment ravis d'avoir savoir sur
le plateau du 13 heures
pour deux choses
elle à la fois pour votre troisième
fille meurt en tant que réalisateur ce
n'est pas tout à fait elle la vie dont
j'ai rêvé % et pour le roi lire donc
vous interprétez % et le rôle-titre au
théâtre de l'odéon
eloignez-vous c'est ce qui a bien sûr
est un très beau rôle que vous avez
refusé par le passé déjà et
qu'est-ce qui a fait que cette fois la
rue nous avait pas que c'était d'être
le roi lear
il ya douze ans andré hugel qui est le
metteur en scène de la pièce
mais pour vous de jouer
ayez à 12 heures je t ai beaucoup plus
jeune et au bois de la vieillesse
et je me disais non pas de questions pas
de décoration c'est pas le moment pour
vous le rallye a fêté le départ je me
couche
pour beaucoup de personnes c'est une
décoration
beaucoup d'acteurs une décoration oui
mais lilly a été fidèle cas deux
jours après il est enseveli lundi alors
les yeux et je vais pour le tout de
suite oui
parce que 12 ans de fidélité de la
part d'un metteur en scène c était
assez rarement on essaiera
et c'est très réussi à moi je suis
allé voir la pièce seillière soient
claires je crois que c'était la
deuxième représentation césarienne
soit pour 100 m c'est vraiment très
très fort ya une magnifique mise en
scène et il faut le dire pour une
distribution est super mais surtout
parce qu'on a l'impression de traverser
avec vous des émotions qui sont à
chaque fois très forte il ya d'abord la
colère
ensuite c'est la trahison ensuite il ya
la folie m moi je sais que j ai envie de
vous demander comment vous faites pour
vous transformer comme ça sur un
plateau à ce point
vous monsieur de je suis plus élevé de
bois pointu qui est lui-même
qui était un grand auteur elle le
confie concombres
quand on parle comme le jury du
théâtre mais c'est aussi une immense
star serait un grand manque à l'appel
ça aide beaucoup pour
justement région de l'est
avec tous ces sentiments
fou de délits et de férocité qui
existe dans ses textes et ses
extraordinaires parce qu'au fur et à
mesure de la pièce on a l'impression à
eux que vous traversez l'esa le cercle
au début ça tout début de l'année
gasquet
à un moment extrêmement vieux que vous
revenez en enfance
comment travailler ça a des sentiments
comme ça à percé à redonner sur
scène sur un plateau par la plus
notable a été effectuée
et juste avant la présentation pendant
deux mois
hollande mois je dirais presque jour et
nuit
c'est l'obsession
et puis - une fois que que je jour où
je suis un petit peu comme un poisson
dans l'eau ouais ça a demandé
elle a un gros travail et ça se voit
que vous êtes comme un poisson dans
l'eau à la représentation des reds au
centre d'hazard 40
pas deux ans carrefour dans les deux cas
par an c'est beaucoup ont déjà elle
était évidemment très très souvent
esseulé sur scène pendant les deux
heures 40
comment on ressort % et d'une
représentation comme ça
qui a demandé une telle application
m
le rendement ressort en tout cas en
très bonne état
des deux journées de répétitions aux
gens sans se voir en très mauvais état
les autres aussi but par ma faute
s'ouvre
peu après la votation en très bonne
état
et la fatigue ne vient que l'une ou deux
heures après
et quand on voit une salle comme ça a
dit hier soir
elky apple 10% qui demandent cinq
rappels est manifestement très
enthousiaste et ce que vous cherchez
piccoli vous êtes encore très
sensibles à ça ou est-ce que leur
après je ne sais pas combien de
représentations théâtre mais bien en
avoir beaucoup plus c'est quelque chose
qui me touche plus
le choûtot me touche mais pourquoi
mais m but du jeu jules julianne
jusqu'à un paradoxe c'est que je me
demande s'il ne serait pas bien que les
acteurs apprennent un peu attention ne
solde pas
que le public reste dans l'imaginaire du
spectacle
et non pas de voir les panthers à dire
merci elle est implantée à merci
elle est plus sûre plus propre et plus
sûre et c'est ce à quoi les
spectateurs et c'est dans leur métier
de manière de vous dire aussi à vous
merci monsieur bien sûr que non mais
j'aime bien il est honnête
contradictions alors justement
% et j'imagine que ça vous agace un peu
que l'on parle de moi en disant c'est un
monstre sacré et du cinéma du
théâtre
ça veut dire quoi mon choix s'est fait
pour s'adapter au seul jacques et
j'accepterai
le sacré cela personne ne nous a fait
de ce match un seul sens
ça m'inquiète un peu
dijon mort du monstre point de
suspension
alors si ça parce que pour un
troisième film en tant que réalisateur
pour ceux qui s intitule donc steel est
pas tout à fait la vie dont j'avais
rêvé % on a vraiment les l'impression
que le parti pris c'est de démonter
dans le nez les spectateurs vers à
l'extravagance
merci lulu sujet buduslau moi-même
les jeunes ne se fait que pourra
inquiéter d'être un petit peu trop
le prétentieux ou présomptueux de mai
merci de dire que les joueurs
entraînés le spectateur de
l'extravagance
mais l'extravagante du quotidien en
chine
c'est une histoire très classique et
dame-marie de sa femme et de sa
maîtresse sera traité de manière
classique et on a l'impression que vous
vous
vraiment d'ailleurs moi-même d'ailleurs
cccc satisfait michel piccoli
elle gardait toujours le lançant
terrible qui a au fond
vous voulez l'enfant qui était au fond
de moi en journée
j'aime bien fouillé l'enfant terrible
qui existent encore je suis chez les
spectateurs qui quelquefois sur le cash
eh bien il faut le refuser western en
france c'est indécent
m pour beaucoup de personnes en claquant
voulez et vous les élus au blizzard et
aux verts les espoirs
j'espère
alors en tout cas le roi lear elle s'est
peut-être de beauté ont jusqu'au 30
mars comme disait le poète au 25 août
public comme ça il faut absolument
aller voir cette série accédants
magnifique et votre film ce n'est pas
tout à fait ce dont j'avais rêvé
il est en salle depuis mercredi dernier
c'est un objet cinématographique
extravagante
merci à vos intérieurs d'être réunis
sur le plateau du 13 heures à la fin de
ce journal merci à vous d'avoir suivi